so we we now have a situation and we're
going to have time to have a
sort of bigger conversation about this
as we get closer and closer to joe
biden's inauguration
but we have a a situation here
where donald trump now has cost the
republican party
everything trump has cost the republican
party
everything he could have cost them
donald trump cost the republican party
the house
in the 2018 midterms donald trump cost
the republican party the senate in the
2020 election
donald trump uh caused himself to be a
one-term
president now putting the republican
party
out of the oval office just 13 days
from now donald trump has cost the
republican party
global shame and embarrassment and has
ruined the careers of many many people
and so we're seeing republicans start to
turn on donald trump
donald trump denounced his own vice
president mike pence yesterday in the
middle of the capitol hill riots that he
incited himself
we saw mick mulvaney who i i learned
during the break
um went from being trump's chief of
staff to like an envoy to i think
ireland
um and and he resigned and there are
thoughts that there may be more
resignations there are thoughts that
uh there are reports that some cabinet
members are thinking about invoking the
25th amendment to try to remove donald
trump
so from the point of view of blame and
from the point of view of holding people
accountable
none of these republic oh sorry i hit my
mic i'm so excited none of these
republicans deserve
to now be praised and to be given a
blank slate because with 13 days to go
they said this is too much for me this
segment is not
about praising the moral republicans
who after three years and eleven and a
half
months are now saying this is too much
for me this is not about that
but this is about what does the future
of the republican party
look like and in particular after this
week not only did donald trump incite
a seditious riot in the capital but he
uh also oversaw the two people he
endorsed kelly lefler
and david perdue lose their senate seats
as incumbent republicans
to democratic challengers raphael
warnock and john ossoff
you are starting to see republicans bail
and
you start to see these reports like we
saw in the week
about republicans privately furious at
trump
over what happened in georgia and
republicans privately furious that trump
put them in a position to have to either
support bogus claims of voter fraud or
have to
denounce donald trump essentially and
risk being on the receiving end of
trump's anger
these republicans are complete fools and
they deserve none of
our pity whatsoever but the question
does become
what happens in the next two years and
in the next four years
and what i care about is is there an
opportunity for joe biden to get things
done
because donald trump has so debased and
destroyed the republican party the
republican party will rebuild
and they may even do well in 2022.
i think it's more likely they do well in
the house than the senate because of the
the
the uh cohort of senate elections that
are taking place in 2022
but the point is i care about progress
and joe biden is going to come in in 13
days and he'll start doing things that
he can do via executive order and that's
going to be fine
and then we don't know if joe biden is
going to get any supreme court picks but
if he does we'll deal with that when it
comes to it
but the real question is going to be
from the big legislative agenda
from the big policy agenda what can joe
biden get done
we've said before these republicans are
going to be
the uh total obstructionists that we've
seen them be in the past
um they are going to get in the way of
joe biden doing almost anything
with control of the senate now 50 50
with kamala harris as the tie-breaking
vote and continued control of the house
with total
government control by democrats there is
now a real possibility that some of the
big agenda items can be done can we do
a big infrastructure green energy
deal uh can we get the public option
done
and reduce the medicare age and make the
other changes that that
joe biden has uh lobbied for or
campaigned on
what is joe biden going to be able to do
in terms of foreign policy and foreign
relations and rebuilding
and the questions around policy are the
same ones
but with much of the republican party
now distancing from trump the question
is
is there anything that can be done that
will get
a few republicans to be allies even if
just for the next two years
that give joe biden the opportunity to
really get some important things done
there are moral questions we could have
an ethical debate about whether
you know wouldn't that of risk
rehabilitating the
reputation of some of these republicans
who don't deserve that reputation to be
real
okay we can have that debate but at the
end of the day
trump had this list of things he was
going to do and he failed to do most of
them and that's great he was going to
you know do his horrible health care
plan he failed
he was going to build a wall and he
failed a lot of the good things he
promised he also failed on 100 million
vaccines by the end of 2020
israeli-palestinian peace you know the
list of things that it would have been
nice to do
that he failed on is also there and
that's what it is the presidency is
ending
what can joe biden get done and is there
any politically strategic way
that these last two weeks during which
trump denounces his own vp
and republicans start to distance these
are still terrible people
but from the totally pragmatic
perspective
can this be leveraged in any way to get
something done
that we really need to get done in this
country we'll leave that question there
and we'll pick it up next week and
certainly
uh when when joe biden is ultimately
sworn in